elle est là elle est belle elle est
planqué ici elle est planqué sous la bvk
cover qui bordent c'est un peu l'étui
c'est un peu le clavier qu'on peut
retrouver ici au niveau de cette table
est on se parle aujourd'hui la samsung
galaxy tab est suite ultra de très
grands modèles extrêmement grand modèle
que je trouve extrêmement intéressante
je vous le dis tout de suite franco de b
on y va parce qu'elle est très grande
elle est peut-être un peu trop grande
tenir l'emmener avec soin regardez ça
c'est une taille qui est quand même
monstrueuse on se parle d'une tablette
c'est un monstre on avait vu déjà arrivé
avec des tablettes du côté de chez apple
les très grands écrans on te dirai quand
même c'est quand même un peu énorme et
là je dois reconnaître que c'est encore
pire quand il repousse les limites
samsung pour autant il s'adresse à des
personnes qui ont besoin de très grands
écrans qui veulent de la modularité qui
valent une tablette a forcément un
ordinateur et qui veulent pour autant
avoir pourquoi pas un petit clavier ici
et qui veulent un aspect n'a pas venir
travailler facilement on va regarder
aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut faire et ce
qu'on ne peut pas faire avec 7 samsung
galaxy tab et suite ultra on va essayer
de comprendre si le format est
intéressant ou s'il forman mais plutôt
comme un boulet au à la cheville au pied
et puis au final si elle est faite pour
vous alors absolument
[Musique]
regardez avant toute chose je veux
commencer par retirer la bvk cover qui
volent parce que même si elle est très
très pratique la tablette vous allez
l'avoir sans et ben oui forcément on
s'en doutera hop là ça s'enlève comme ça
vous avez donc votre tablette l'arbre a
même enlevé le s pen qui est là comme ça
on se retrouve avec la tablette juste nu
comme ça alors cette table est allé
intéressante pourquoi parce qu'en fait
samsung nous a fait un truc super
intéressant c'est la première fois que
je vois arriver une tablette aussi
grande de 14,6 pouces c'est la taille
d'un écran d'ordinateur je peux pas dire
autrement c'est la taille d'un écran
d'ordinateur ces aidants c'est une très
très grosse tablette alors on se dirait
ok pour moi une tablette c'est quoi ces
10 11 12 pouces 12 pouces c'est déjà une
très grosse tablette et là vous avez une
tablette qui juste monstrueux donc très
clairement pour autant est-ce que cette
taille ce format peut-être un handicap
alors moi je pense que cette tablette en
fait en ayant utilisé on a fait plein de
choses avec pour moi cette tablette elle
est destinée vraiment pour la maison
alors ça veut pas dire pouvaient pas
l'emmener si on peut l'emmener mais
c'est une tablette est fait pour la
maison parce qu'elle est très grande à
la différence d'une tablette un peu plus
petit qu'on va enlever facilement
emporter avec soi celle là il va rester
davantage à la maison alors vous me
direz ok t'es bien mignon mais un
ordinateur portable des 15 pouces on
peut les emmener avec nous il ya des
sacs c'est ça ou je suis d'accord mais
ça reste une tablette et pour moi cette
tablette elle n'a pas vocation à venir
se balader partout tout le temps
d'ouvrir en permanence elle peut le
faire attention on peut l'emmener avec
soin mais je pense que le vrai visage
les âges trois quarts des usages
principaux ça va être des usages
domestiques alors vous me direz ok il ya
le bouc cover qui bordent qu'on peut
prendre avec qu'on va acheter à part
dans le détail et dans quelques instants
parce que c'est pas cadeau ça coûte
quand même relativement cher ça vient
faire deux choses sont beaucoup verts
qui bordent ça vient déjà la protéger ce
qui est quand même plutôt pas mal et
vous venez au plat en deux parties vous
clipser à le clavier que vous avez là
c'est le premier point et puis deuxième
point vous venez de mettre ça au dos là
qui est aimanté et là hop là regardez
pas plaint jamais de bien d'en face est
monté dur voilà et là il est bien
positionnée donc ça vous le protège à
l'avant à l'arrière il ya un petit côté
chevalet bon cet accessoire éric houle
qui coûte cher et il faut bien l'acheter
en plus après il ya c'est malin parce
que vous avez le petit logement pour le
s pen là comme ça hop là il se prend il
se positionne la ola là il est
positionné sur ferme et il est planqué
donc ça c'est plutôt cool donc là
effectivement j'ai un objet nomade parce
que jusque pas de régaler cran lorsque
je le mets dans une sacoche je le
protège mais ça augmente
significativement les coûts et déjà
khattab est et très cher en ml on n'est
plus bon ok t'es bien mignon ça coûte
quand même très très très très cher donc
effectivement c'est un objet qu'on va
garder à la maison pour plusieurs usages
usage numéro un c'est quoi alors avec
beaucoup qui bordent où son beau
couleurs qui borde le bouc cover qui
bordent il va apporter un truc c'est
quoi et bien c'est le fait qu'en fait
vous allez pouvoir le poser comme ça
extrêmement facilement regardez vous
venez vous la poser comme ça avec votre
boule koller qui vendent alors attendez
gimont capteur d'empreintes digitales je
viens au plat donc là en fait ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que je peux
l'utiliser pour me regarder du contenu
multimédia extrêmement facilement donc
ça c'est très très très pratique donc
effectivement mais après venir acheter
un bouc cover qui bordent qui peut quand
même relativement cher pour venir me
faire un coup de multimédia je sais pas
si c'est vraiment la bonne idée bon ça
c'est quand même aussi plutôt pas mal de
se dire on peut y voir ces pratiques
donc vous avez votre côté multimédia
radich le bassin qu'ils peuvent pour
vous puissiez voir donc pour venir
regarder des films des séries à netflix
dernier par exemple j'aime choisir un
truc au catalogue de netflix très
facilement je me suis regardé a perdu
dans l'espace je m'en mettre un petit
épisode là attention spoiler alert donc
voyez alors après le truc est tout un
peu on le voit il se réfléchit
énormément cet écran donc là vous devez
me voir à travers l'écran mais je peux
venir après monter la luminosité donc là
je suis en luminosité max le seul truc
c'est que et ben c'est un vrai petit
miroir donc là moi je me vois à travers
pas si vous me voyez pas ce qu'il y'a
pas la colorimétrie moment où je regarde
mais on se voit donc il faut quand même
qu'on est assez peu de lumière derrière
ce en quoi ça réfléchit quand même
plutôt pas mal ça s'appelle donc un
petit peu contraignant après si vous
avez des vidéos avec beaucoup de lumière
ce qui n'est pas le cas dans cette série
là je vous met par exemple ça donne dans
l'espace en truquant l'extérieur voyez
tout de suite ça réfléchit un peu moins
bon quand même un petit peu mais c'est
quand même un petit peu moins donc films
séries on est d'accord parce que vous
avez une très grande diagonale en plus
ici comme ça un écran super amoled
extrêmement bien maîtrisée de la part de
samsung il ya aucun problème ça marche
du feu de dieu autre point qui vachement
bien pour cette expérience multimédia
c'est que vous avez des hauts parleurs
stéréo même si vous en avez 4 vous en
avez d'autres chaque côté en haut là
regardez là vous en avait un qui situe
là vous en avez un autre qui se situe là
et vous avez la même chose de l'autre
côté un l'a1 là ça vient renforcer en
fait si vous voulez le l'expérience
audio vous en avez un peu plus alors
pour autant c'est pas là vont avoir un
spectre anodin je m'attendrais que ces
quatre haut parleurs à ce qui nous est
fait un truc avec un peu plus de grave
on reste quand même dans un médium
médium large attention c'est parti 4e de
la liga comme ça c'est du médium large
mais c'est pas là où on avoir la
meilleure expérience audio ça fonctionne
très bien attention ça fonctionne
vraiment très très bien mais on n'a pas
un peu de rondeur on reste sur une
tablette il faut le savoir donc là
dessus pas de soucie pas de mauvaises
surprises coup et me rappellerai après
des galaxies mode si vous le souhaitez
ou n'importe quel autre casque grâce au
bluetooth 5.2 donc ça aussi c'est plutôt
cool je dirais pour tous qu'il est multi
média divertissement vous allez ce qui
va bien alors après on va dire
divertissement a diverti c'est
intéressant bah oui on peut venir se
faire également des jeux allez je vous
met par exemple un petit asphalte neuf
histoires de venir se marrer alors
l'asfac neuf il est assez intéressant
parce que comme j'ai ici - lebouc cover
qui borde et bien je peux lire jouer
directement avec mon clavier vous pouvez
lire jouer aussi directement sur votre
tablette si vous le souhaitez je vais
vous montrer un peu comment ça se passe
regardez par exemple on va se faire une
petite partie est alors soit je peux
venir jouer avec ma tablette avec mes
boutons mais c'est quand même très très
grand donc pour venir la tenir en main
c'est pascal plus dingues si vous avez
le boucau verts qui bordent va vous
augmenter un petit peu d'expérience je
vais venir jouer ici avec mes boutons là
je vais avoir mon petit turbo regardez
je vous montrais l'histoire on soit une
partie de la très courte parce qu'en
plus comme vous avez ici à sa dragonne 8
jane wan jen 1 bat sa tartine du feu de
dieu envers les hopla l'aop l'âge avance
les petits 360 des familles histoire de
marée au plat donc là c'est vachement
pratique mais voyez déjà on a un truc
qui est quand même relativement sympa et
qui fonctionne bien voilà là ça peut
être des bagnoles ça fait n'importe quoi
ça va dans tous les sens comme ça je
peux faire des touristes bouger tous les
côtés enfin bref je me fais plaisir donc
ça c'est vrai que c'est plutôt sympa
j'ai l'impression de retrouver un côté
un peu guignard je suis pas gamer
attention donc je veux pas non plus dire
n'importe quoi mais je trouve qu'ils
racontent un peu gaming de venir jouer
effectivement avec son petit clavier
comme ça ça c'est assez marrant alors ça
reste quand même un truc est assez light
pas parce qu'on est quand même sur une
tablette mais malgré tout il ya un truc
qui est très sympa et qui fonctionnera
plutôt pas mal en quoi les aplats je
fais mon finish open petite pirouette
est terminée donc ça c'est vrai que
c'est plutôt cool ça fonctionne bien
vous avez reste un dragon 8 de première
génération donc il va très très bien
qu'il va apporter beaucoup de fluidité
ça c'est bien et après vous avez le
choix vous allez avoir soit 8 gigas de
ram soit 12 il ya drame soit 16 giga de
ram vous avez différentes configurations
entre la wii fit et la 5g mais je
voulais explique dans quelques instants
parce que oui comme on a un sens
dragonne 8 de première génération on a
de la 5g enfin pas tout le temps on peut
avoir l'option 5 g mais sinon à l'option
wifi moi je vous conseille de prendre
wifi ça coûtera moins cher et comme vous
allez utiliser à la maison ça sera
largement suffisant le stockage c'est
pareil 128 256 ou 512 go si vous avez
une grosse batterie de 11200
milliampères heures avec de la recharge
45 watts alors je doive c'est quand même
le grand minimum d'avoir une recharge 45
watts a mis du temps honnêtement il faut
un peu s'armer de patience pour la
recharger à 100% que ce que je vous
conseille c'est de temps en temps vous
venez un peu la branche et histoire que
ça fonctionne mais bon l'autonomie cela
dépend de vous de vos usages pour rester
une bonne journée sans problème si vous
utilisez assez peu ça va durer un peu
plus dans le temps ça va dépendre une
fois de plus de ce que vous allez en
faire on n'est pas sur un smartphone
donc ça fait exactement la même chose
après il ya un truc que j'aime bien ici
c'est toute l'expérience software on est
survenu à diwan j'aime beaucoup alors je
vous ai déjà expliqué présenté aux
nuages on est sur un nuage une tablette
mais ça reste du magnoac c'est
exactement la même chose que je me
trouvais sur un smartphone adaptée à la
tablette bon c'est que la rc lisible
vous et tous vos paramètres je vous
passe un peu le truc très très rapide le
truc est sympa aussi sur cette tablette
là c'est que vous avez un taux de
rafraîchissement variable qui va jusqu'à
120 air donc pour du gaming savent
apporter de la fluidité donc ça c'est
aussi très très très bien vous avez une
belle résolution en 2009 160 par 1848
moi je trouve bien vraiment vraiment
bien cette dalle très bien calibrée
super beau boulot maintenant il ya un
truc on aime on n'aime pas passer cette
petite encoche c'est la première fois
qu'ils nous font ch et ça me semble
encore généralement c'est plutôt apple
qui fait des encoches muizon fait une
petite encoche alors je l'oublié très
honnêtement on ne peut pas dire que je
n'oublie pas mais c'est vrai que c'est
surprenant alors c'est encore à elle a
un sens pourquoi parce qu'elle abrite
une double caméra de 12 mégapixels 12-12
grand angle ultra grand-angle alors vous
allez me dire ça sert à quoi cette
histoire fait ça sert pour le côté
vision pour le côté communication avec
des amis et de la famille ça vous fait
la même chose qu'on va retrouver
aujourd'hui chez apple sur un ipad vous
savez l'histoire de deux caméras centre
et qui suivent sur les mouvements alors
gardez vous faire une petite démo ans
faire un petit appel vidéo des familles
alors regardez là moi je me mets là et
en fait ça va me suivre donc c'est à
dire que je me déplace le voyez la
caméra elle me suis ici je me recule hop
elle va reculer aussi un peu et si je me
rapproche eh ben elle fait le boulot
pour avoir un vrai suivi comme ça voyez
où je sois donc ça c'est quand même
vachement pratique et ça c'est vachement
bien alors c'est pas tout nouveau c'est
un truc qui existaient déjà et qu'on
voyait déjà à la concurrence mais c'est
vrai qu'ici il ya un côté qui est aussi
très sympa et une fois de plus dans
l'idée de la productivité pouvez
utiliser avec un zoom vous disais qu'un
google duo avec ce que vous voulez donc
ça c'est bien et c'est bienvenu alors
après l'arrière qui vous ont mis
également une double double module photo
vous allez me retrouver ici vous avez un
13 mégapixels et vous avez en 6
mégapixels est ce que pour autant je
vais venir utiliser la caméra arrière de
ma tablette moi je suis pas du tout
convaincu alors on peut bien le faire
est-ce qu'on va utiliser pour faire des
photos de nom pour moi ont un smartphone
et le smartphone suffira pour ça le truc
et gros vous n'avez pas emmener votre
tablette rdr je vais aller faire les
photos paf paf non ça marche pas donc
bon on peut les avoir on peut faire des
choses pour autant est-ce qu'on va le
faire je n'y crois pas je ne pense pas
et ça ne me semble pas être très
pratique en termes d'usagé après l'autre
truc qui est aussi très sympa c'est que
bien vous pouvez venir faire vous de la
vidéo si vous voulez vous enregistrez
redéposer dire film et jusqu en 4k usd
là je me suis mis c'est là celle à 30
images par seconde c'est le match que je
puisse faire aussi
à l'avant alors si vous voulez film à
l'arrière vous pouvez aussi regarder
vous monte également en nuage des à 30
images par seconde je ne suis pas
convaincu qu'on vienne utilisés pour
faire de la vidéo mais si on souhaite on
peut le faire voilà cent enregistré un
petit message pour votre famille vous
envoyé un petit truc assez sympa
pourquoi vous avez trois micros pour la
réduction de bruit lorsque vous allez
venir parler ça va capter les sons
ambiants ça va capter votre voix ça va
annuler tous les parasites pour
optimiser réellement votre voix donc
c'est plutôt sympa et puis après il ya
tout un côté écosystèmes dont je vous ai
déjà parlé lors d'une précédente vidéo
savoir comment est-ce que je l'utilisé
avec mon s22 ultra je vous mets le lien
de la vidéo soit par la soie en bas dans
la description est jetable degré parce
que c'est vrai que c'est intéressant et
ça vous montre un peu ce qu'on peut
faire avec ould cheikh partager des
choses très facilement donc voilà ça
fonctionne bien alors moi je me compare
a effectivement dû s pen parce que quand
on parle de tablettes qu'on se parle de
ça on a forcément un petit espagne pour
votre respect vous avez hop là de la
prise de notes si vous le souhaitez vous
pouvez lire dessinée griffonné faire ce
que vous voulez alors moi n'étant pas un
illustrateur graphiste c'est pas moi qui
vous donnez le meilleur feedback le
meilleur feedback je les ai eus avec une
illustratrice que j'ai rencontré qu'il
utilisait avec qui j'ai pu parler j'ai
vu un destinée c'est très très très
bluffant brian m'a dit en fait cette
tablette pour moi elle est intéressant
parce que j'ai un vrai retour je sens
vraiment ma mine sous mon doigt et j'ai
l'expérience d'un touché papier alors
c'est pas réellement vrai parce que on
sent effectivement un peu d'eux un petit
retour sous le doigt on n'a pas le vrai
côté comme si on dessinait sur un bout
de papier mais malgré tout vous avez la
mine qui s'enfonce très très légèrement
votre bile qui s'enfonce très légèrement
on a un petit retour on a une petite
sensation effectivement lorsqu'on vient
dessiner écrire coucou toi alors c'est
pas exactement comme sur du papier mais
le retour effectivement de sept
personnes qui étaient illustratrice qui
ignorent toujours je pense illustratrice
m'a dit la sensation est vraiment
agréable beaucoup de plaisir à dessiner
avec beaucoup de plaisir à travailler
avec donc superbe outil aura pris une
fois de plus je suis pas graphiste c'est
pas moi qui vais venir vous donner les
meilleures astuces et les meilleurs
conseils mais de ce que j'en ai vu de ce
que j'ai écouté ça fonctionne bien et là
dessus il absolument aucun problème une
avancée extrêmement faibles 4096 pour
une pression faire bref un truc qui
marche très très très bien vous avez
également les paires jester venir faire
des choses à distance directement et hop
là vous me dire utiliser ça peut venir
après créer une note affichée les notes
sélection intelligente la traduction
enfin bref ya beaucoup de choses qu'on
peut lui dire faire ici a directement et
ça c'est plutôt cool une tablette
connectée une tablette effectivement qui
a tout ce qui vient de lui aujourd'hui
vous du wifi 6e vous dis moi je
conseille vraiment dresser sur la
version wifi versus la version 5 g que
je trouvais un peu plus cher à moins que
vous ayez une fois de plus des besoins
de mobilité mais pour moi ça sert à rien
parce que c'est une tablette qui va
rester à la maison et même si vous avez
besoin à l'extérieur une fois de
l'emmener de vous connecter peut-être
partage de connexion depuis votre
smartphone et ça conviendra parfaitement
bien alors il ya un truc dont je veux
qu'on parle maintenant moi c'est la
boucle aux verts qui bordent parce que
cette boue koller qui borde le matériel
alors effectivement il ya un certain
prix et je vous donne tous les tarifs en
quelques instants je joue pas le teaser
mais comme ça vous a tous les tarifs des
crises est intéressant alors beaucoup
air keyboard dock et d'une elle vient la
protégée de elle vient planquer le style
est ici 3 sam sarr de chevalet pour
venir utiliser avaler des films des
séries et tout ça c'est plutôt bien si
j'ai plus besoin du clavier pas je
détache et j'utilise comme ça en me de
cheval et je suis à la cool et lorsque
j'ai besoin d'écrire et ben je prends
mon clavier alors mon clavier il
intéressant pour plusieurs points parce
que déjà vous avez un grand trackpad qui
vous permet de naviguer extrêmement
facilement et moi je trouve ça vachement
confort et ça ça me plaît bien et puis
vous avez plein de petits raccourcis qui
sont super cools or déjà regarder là
vous avez ici un petit bouton pour venir
activer le decs le dec c'est quoi ça
vous le pas dans un mode un peu
ordinateur regarder up l'aja puis je
switche directement en mode d'aix donc
là je vais retrouver après mes
différentes applications venir utiliser
le dax et compagnie et lorsque je veux
plus je fais fn d'aix et je sort
directement de nomades ex donc ça c'est
plutôt cool autre truc que je peux venir
faire est bien à l'ordre effectivement
ses montées leçon baisser le son la
luminosité plus la luminosité - il ya
trois touches qu'on peut devenir
complètement personnalisé pour appeler
les applications qu'on veut et f1 f2 f3
et ça c'est très très cool alors moi je
les assigner à différentes applications
regardez par exemple je fais fn et hop
f1 ça vient d'ouvrir directement youtube
plein voilà donc la chaîne youtube
ensuite fait f2 ça m'ouvre netflix et je
fais f3 et f3 ça va venir à m'ouvrir ici
mon navigateur internet après pouvez
faire ce que vous voulez si fidèles sur
une application vous les cfl plus la
touche appuyez vous souhaitez pendant
quelques secondes ça va l'enregistrer
directement et ça va la tribu et donc
voilà après vous avez aussi un autre qui
est super intéressant c'est regarder la
cette petite touche là là que vous voyez
qui est là là au niveau de la touche tab
ça en fait ça fait quoi permet
d'utiliser votre clavier en bluetooth
sur un autre appareil et là je vous
montre notamment sur un galaxy s 22
ultra donc là ce que je fais je fais
bien fn et table à la salle ont affiché
un petit message voilà ça va envoyer
vers le es22 ultra2 qu'aurélien eu
maintenant lorsque j'ai mon s22 la haye
et dans la zone de texte jeu taper un
message coucou toi j'espère que tu vas
bien points et du coup je viens taper
directement là je suis heureux de voir
mon lapin des îles voilà comme ça voyez
il ya un truc qui est quand même super
sympa et je vous le montre un jeu
m'avait vraiment plan l'agencé un peu
compliqué je sais de vous montrer mais
je vous assure que c'est moi qui suis en
train de le taper en même temps en temps
on décide de faire un truc un peu comme
ça dans la peau des deals points à la
prochaine prends soin de toi et vous
l'avez directement l'aï ensuite lorsque
je veux venir sont chez et ben je fais
exactement la même chose je reviens là
haut up la fn tab et je switche et je
suis à nouveau sur ma table et suit le
message était arrivé un peu après donc
ça c'est quand même vachement pratique
parce que effectivement ce book cover
qui bordent on va se dire bon bah
effectivement ça te protège nous un
petit clavier mais en fait ça transforme
votre tablette un petit ordinateur pour
la maison parce que l'idée de cette
tablette là on est à plus de 1000 euros
la tablette -un soyons clair donc on va
pas venir l'utiliser uniquement par des
films des séries sont quoi vous avez le
tab et suite qui a très bien au delà
cette de l'année dernière n'a pas besoin
de ça mais si vous voulez celle-là on la
veut pour l' usage mixte on l'avait
aussi bien pour de la productivité
pouvoir gérer ses comptes pouvoir faire
des emails à pouvoir faire du traitement
de texte très facilement mais on veut
également pouvoir quoi avoir un côté il
ya les tablerait compagnie mais on peut
aussi faire du divertissement ça peut
être d'une aide publique je veux montrer
ce prêtre mais canal ça peut être
prendre sa perte tout ce que vous voulez
youtube pour dire regardez monsieur rhin
n'est ce pas déjà penser à bien vos
abonnés qu'ils sont petits boutons
rouges si les rouches et vous n'êtes pas
abonné puis actionnez la cloche pour
totti filets qu'une prochaine vidéo
arrivera que vous soyez abonné aux pas
fait le ser portant des verres il faut
être abonné site on peut patiner actes
donc abonnez vous on y va et puis bien
évidemment pour toi laisse écouter de la
musique si on veut également là dessus
naviguer sur internet sur la recherche
donc ça remplace un ordinateur si vous
n'avez pas besoin d'une bécane d'un
ordinateur avec une grosse carte
graphique qui vous sera dédiée on peut
très bien venir acheter aujourd'hui 7
samsung galaxy tab et suite ultras qui
conviendra très bien qui est en fait
très complète j'ai pas l'air passe
partout parce qu'elle est très grosse
mais en fait vous pouvez tout faire avec
quasiment tout faire même des petits
logiciels d'édition vidéo on peut le
faire mais très très light option va pas
être très loin on peut faire un dut
lightroom vous et montrez moi déjà dans
la précédente vidéo comme enjeu venir
toucher mes photos directement ici et
sur lightroom avec mon espèce donc on
peut faire des millions de choses donc
c'est en ça que cette tablette j'aime
bien alors attention une fois de plus il
vous faut le budget derrière parce
qu'elle coûte extrêmement cher si une
vidéo que j'ai fait sur les derniers
smartphones smartphone de samsung voilà
je joue vraiment très rapidement une
fois de plus donc voyez on peut bien
faire énormément de choses et c'est en
ça que je trouve cette tablette j'm'en
bien mais alors regardez je manquais
tarifs sur votre table est ultra vous
avez plusieurs config vous avez une
config qu'on va appeler la config wifi
et vous avez la config 5 et là vous avez
ensuite plusieurs trucs vous allez avoir
du 8 +128 ici on n'a pas de 5 g vous
avez la config 12 + 2 156 et vous avez
la config 16 plus 512 en 8 +128 vous
êtes à
1219 euros c'est cher c'est très cher 12
156 en wifi 1319 euro fort a ajouté 1000
euros de plus pour avoir un peu plus de
stockage un peu plus de rendre plus de
fluidité mais si vous êtes un version 5
gc 1479 euros tandis que la version 16
512 c1
1549 euros directement la en wifi et
1699 euros dont vous voyez ces prix d'un
ordinateur en réalité vraiment donc pour
vraiment réfléchir à ce qu'on veut faire
est ce que on a besoin du style pour moi
la vraie grosse différence est aussi le
stylet et puis vous avez également le
bouc cover qui bordent hop là je vous le
mets comme ça qu'il faut venir ajouté
qui lui coûte 349 euros 90 bon dont vous
voyez c'est quand même un petit budget
parce que là on est à 350 euros et même
si vous prenez cette version là vous
voyez tout de suite ça fait quand même
un vrai petit budget mais bon voilà moi
je trouve intéressant donc si vous avez
des usages avec un espèce si vous voulez
une très grande table est une très belle
table est performante puissante et que
vous allez garder dans les années à
venir vous pouvez y aller parce qu'elle
est vraiment hyper canon si maintenant
vous n'avez pas besoin du spl si
maintenant vous n'avez pas besoin d'un
grand écran comme ça et si vous n'avez
pas besoin de cette performance que vous
pouvez très bien aller vers une galaxy
tab et suit plus ou une galaxy tab et
suit alors la table suite c'est pas du
super amoled c'est du lcd mais bon on a
quand même derrière ce qu'ils font donc
il faut vraiment venir voir vous et vos
usages j'espère que vous aurez aider en
vous montrant tout ça moi j'aime
beaucoup ton extrêmement intéressant
cher mais intéressante et un très très
beau travail une fois de plus fait ici
par samsung et ça c'est plutôt chouette
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
en barrant commentaires souder les
questions interrogations suggestions
pouvez y aller ces commentaires sont
faits pour ça et puis moi je me
demandais où très vite pour continuer
bien évidemment à part les tec embrasse
pour les soins vous beaucoup
d'importance
[Musique]
où